three of hong kong's most well-known
pro-democracy activists have been
sentenced to prison
joshua wong will spend around 13 months
in jail while agnes chao
will spend 10 months for their role in
last month's
last year's protests another activist
ivan lamb will be in prison for seven
months
demonstrations outside hong kong's
police headquarters in 2019 were
triggered by the introduction
of a controversial extradition bill
which has
since been shelved let's go live out of
hong kong al jazeera's adrian brown is
outside
the courthouse there adrian tell us more
about these sentences
well adrian the latest chapter in hong
kong's continuing
political drama has been taking place
here at west kowloon magistrates court
where
within the past hour the best known
young
political activist in hong kong joshua
wong has been sentenced
to 13 and a half months in jail he was
convicted
of inciting uh an unlawful assembly
as well as organizing an unlawful
assembly
agnes chao his close friend and
colleague in the
ongoing protest movement was convicted
uh given a 10-month sentence for
participating in
an illegal assembly and also a second
charge of
helping organize it the third person
ivan lam
received a seven month sentence now they
had faced
possibly a maximum sentence of up to
three
years but in spite of all that agnes
chao
is still in a pretty serious situation
because four months ago
she was arrested under the new national
security law
on suspicion of colluding with foreign
powers now she's been out on bail
or had been until she pleaded guilty a
week ago
and if she is convicted though on that
uh
if she is charged and convicted she
faces the prospect of you know
life in jail now barely a week goes by
adrian
without you know a young activist being
prosecuted in court
since early last june more than ten
000 people have been arrested a thousand
of them
are under the age of 18 and so far
there have been a total of just over 2
300 prosecutions it means
that the courts here in hong kong are
becoming clogged
in fact they're still processing people
who were
arrested during the occupy umbrella
movement
seven years ago so this is something
that's going to
tie up the courts for you know weeks
perhaps you know
years to come we know that uh joshua
wong
is no stranger of course to jail he has
done three
stints in prison before this will be his
his fourth
and of course he's been arrested no less
than 10
times it means of course that agnes chao
who turns 24 on thursday will be
spending
her birthday beginning a 10-month jail
sentence and remember
these three activists are all under the
age of 26 yet in many ways
they are now veterans of of the
pro-democracy movement
why adrian did the three plead guilty
well they decided to plead guilty uh
nine days ago after consultations
with their lawyers it hasn't been
explained exactly why
they decided to do that but of course it
meant that they avoided
a a lengthy trial perhaps they felt that
by pleading guilty they would get
a a shorter sentence they were certainly
facing the prospect of up to three years
in jail because that's the maximum
sentence
a magistrate's court here in hong kong
can give
but the fact that they have received you
know sentences in excess of six months
i think will probably bring a lot of
critical comments from
many governments around the world
especially the incoming
uh biden administration in the united
states because
the president-elect has said that he
believes that
china will be his foreign policy
priority and of course hong kong
in many ways is at the center of all of
that
al jazeera's adrian brown reporting live
there from hong kong adrian many thanks
indeed